the nine-year nfl veteran who is here
courtesy of his partnership with
kingsford
anthony spice adams on the rich eisen
show how have you been sir
i'm great man how you doing i am better
for talking to you
man your feed cracks me up your feed
absolutely cracks me up
it's great oh man thank you man that's
what it's all about man
just uh having smiles all around and
especially times like these man this is
a difficult time right now oh it sure is
let's talk a little bit of uh a little
bit of your chicago bears coming off the
bye week they had a good week
[Music]
no they had a good week they had a good
week the packers lost the vikings lost
and now we had a bye week
it was good it was a very it was like
the best bye week they could possibly
have
what do you think needs to be done with
that team if if if uh
ryan pace and the mccaskey family called
you up
uh coach nagy calls up anthony spice at
him and says what do you think so what
do you think
spice oh my gosh uh it would be the
longest car ever i mean where do you
start i mean it's like
it's like going into a room and you see
like a pile of clothes
and all these different spaces and
you're like i don't know where to start
um i don't know it's just it's
inconsistent man
we don't know where our identity is i
mean i think our defense is
good not great but i mean like sometimes
we want to feel
more than we need to be and it's just i
don't know man it's just
it's so inconsistent man that's that's
our identity
inconsistency so i mean i would have a
lot of questions man but
you know um they could still write all
of their i mean we could still
beat the packers somehow and you know
somehow
go on a run i don't know but sometimes
it's just
you got to get hot at the right time and
do you think uh trubisky has run his
course there
or you think he should get one more shot
here when he comes back
what do you think i don't know it's kind
of difficult man when you go into year
three and then you get benched
and then they find somebody to a huge
deal it's kind of like the writing is on
the wall so
um if it was me playing defensive tackle
i know i'm out of there i'm gone like
i knew that when i was with san fran i
was packing my stuff
i had boxes in my apartment in october
like i knew what time it was so i mean
the writing
seems to be on the wall why did you have
boxes in october of 2006
spice why because i knew i knew it was
over for me
i already knew like you don't have to
tell it's
sometimes coaches they'll have you in
their office
and it's a lot of coach talk yeah you
know it's a numbers game
and uh we want to try to get you in
there without another guy and
it's like you can you see it and so it's
like you know what
i'm going to call you half give me a
couple boxes little wardrobe boxes i'm
going to go ahead and just pack this
stuff
up because it seems like i'm going to be
out here well spice what happens in a
locker room when a defense is balling
out and the offense is struggling
i mean um obviously chicago right now
you saw
uh the dolphins make a switch um in the
middle of a game
after making a switch supposedly for the
rest of the season a few weeks ago what
what happens in a locker room like that
well i'm a different type of guy i
always see the glass half full
so i'm always like well if the offense
doesn't score
then you know i can't i can't it's
nothing you could really say
if uh offense goes out there and they
put 21 points up on you like what can
you say to the offense let's go
like come on wake up like we don't want
you to wake up they just scored three
touchdowns on us
so i always put the onus on myself and
because
i figured like if you put it on the
kicker why don't you go out and kick
and see what that looked like you go out
and kick a field goal you see what that
look like so i always try to put
uh the shoe on the other foot and see
what it's like to go out there and play
a quarterback like
you don't know you don't know like
different blitzes and all that stuff
all that type of stuff that comes but we
were a different type of defense like we
were trying to get the ball
out we were trying to get the ball we
were trying to score that's all we
practiced when we got the ball everybody
was going to get a block
you didn't go get a block we were
talking about you the coaches were
putting the red dot laser on you
all when we were watching the film so we
were we had a different mindset
our mindset was if the offense can give
us two touchdowns or maybe even 17
points
we supposed to win the game and and then
at the end of the day you had to kick
the devin hester
like so pick your poison like we man we
were well on
scene anthony spice adams here on the
rich eisen show warren sapp always told
me that
uh he would tell everybody don't mess
with my quarterback or my kicker he
doesn't want anybody getting in their
skulls period end this story right you
said that
hard position that's what he said you
know all the time
so um all right uh do you want to talk
about your alma mater or should we just
leave that alone
because i don't like talking about my
alma mater that much these days do you
want to talk about your alma mater
huh you know i mean we i don't i mean
we're
that's that's coming up this week spice
it's michigan versus
penn state um this week oh my gosh
yeah that's coming up i mean do you want
to put anything on this game
any way shape or form you know you know
what you know
you know what i want to put on this game
what
kingsbury pellets that's all i want to
talk about
you want to talk about your sponsorship
is that it's from the camera
oh my god how about those pellets huh
how about those pellets
i'm glad you asked i'm glad you act rich
yeah
i'm so glad you ain't because i don't
have to talk about
my alma mater i said i wasn't gonna cry
roy firestone i said i was not gonna cry
but i love the smoky flavor from king's
propellant man 100
wood smoke flavor imparted onto your
food
man come on it's 100 hardwood smoke
all right you don't get that from other
pellets we're not even going to talk
about other pellets
because we're only talking about case
repellents we're not talking we're not
going to talk about the bears
we're not going to talk about penn state
we're going to talk about
grilling because a lot of people they
going in the oven when they make turkey
no
you got to get on the grill put it on
the smoke baby you know what i'm saying
what you do rich what you do with your
bird
um i put it in the oven i put it in the
oven
yeah i put it on front street uh i put
it on the oven you didn't even know how
to answer that
[Laughter]
well that's because i i watched three
overtimes against rutgers this weekend
um spice you know but before i
i finally got out of the oven you know
you're in a bad spot
hey you're in a bad spot i don't know
three over
[Music]
yes i know but it's so rare for me to be
able to talk smack about my
uh my my football program right now
but uh i kind of feel like i can right
the thing now i've never been in this
position where i
couldn't at least say one thing where
i'm just like oh well that's why we beat
y'all this year or
ah we won by a field goal like it's it's
nothing i could say and then
this this is what makes it so hurtful
rich
my son comes up to me and he says hey
dad
they say penn state the last time penn
state went on for
was 2001. you were on that team right
dad
i said no i never went on four did you
crazy
he said dad i'ma look it up i say i
don't care what you do
you can look it up you can research it i
don't care what you i never went on for
so he looked it up on google and then
google he says look dad says right here
you lost to miami then you lost i said i
said i never went on fire
fantastic fantastic the google being the
eye in the sky that does not lie right
there oh my gosh but hey look at least
we got that going for us it's gonna be a
big game coming up on saturday and
and um you know i'll i'll send you a
direct message after that
um after and ask you how your i'll show
you how your thanksgiving uh with your
char with your
with your uh kingsford pellets one i can
pretty much ask you that oh man
thanksgiving is synonymous with family
football and enjoying extravagant feats
i love it man always be selling hey um
look before
we we retouch upon one more time about
your uh your thanksgiving
um i want to ask you about your alter uh
ego and hoops
uh cream e biggums um and the next time
that we might be able to see him out
there on the floor uh doing his thing
spice oh you know everybody's signing
these max contracts man they need to get
at least creams
at least half of it you know a quarter
of it you know i mean the guy averages
the quintupled double
i mean points rebounds steals
assists blocks quintuple doubles man
every time you touch the court but i
think that's why people don't want to
sign them because it's like a slaughter
if he's on your team you're
automatically going to win the playoffs
and you're going to win the championship
easy so i'm i'm seeing you right here
uh trying to take common off the dribble
um at the all-star game that just went
down in chicago
uh earlier this year um breakdown uh
then powered by quentin richardson oh
yeah we could see q
uh once you beat common off the dribble
he q is ready to
to make sure you didn't get to the rim
uh what is creamy biggum's game
can you break it down for me um spice
i don't think it can be broke down you
know um
it's it's very unorthodox
and uh the true story to make a long
story longer
sure uh uh kareem abdul-jabbar
yes really idolized cream so you know
because at first he was louis
cinder yes but then he changed his name
to korean
cream cream kareem see what i'm saying
so he idolized cream big gums and the
hook shot and the jab steps and the
crossovers
all of that stuff i mean you talk about
an all-around guy who can play defense
who can play
offense he can run a point plays at
least 12
positions even though it's only five on
the court because he can play
assistant coach head coach equipment
manager
anything man this guy is one of the best
i've ever seen so you're saying creamy
biggums is so ahead of his time
he was ahead of his time even before his
time even existed that's what you're
saying
with kareem abdul-jabbar that's what
you're saying
far ahead of the game he's about to
start another life look behind you he's
about to pass you twice
i think i'm i'm i'm i just love the
outside shot that's my favorite gif that
i see sometimes just the uh there's
so many people so many people who want
to actually use a gif to say somebody's
so
far off the mark that i see your your
shot from three point
basically chip the top of the backboard
is one of my favorite three-point shots
i've ever seen
just amazing really is great the thing
is rich
he lacks no like he has all the
confidence in the world
like it doesn't matter like he has the
green light to pull from half court if
he wants to
like that's that's the guy you're
dealing with this is the guy that you
see
in the gym when you go shirts and skins
and this guy is
always in there ready for shirts of
course
i love it uh so what is your
thanksgiving uh favorite thanksgiving
meal
uh that you got spice give it to me
before i let you go
i i smoke a turkey and uh sometimes i uh
i bake and weave it
the kids love it man of course i use the
kingsborough colored grills man i just i
like that smoke flavor because sometimes
you can put
something on an open fire but to just
put something
slow and low and just let the smoke do
the work
it's unreal like that smoke flavor like
really like i know i joke around all the
time man but
i don't joke around when it comes to the
food no doubt and and you're the the
side that you can't do without
what's the sign oh um
i would say macaroni and cheese
and i mean you can you can put all type
of cheese you can put seven cheeses in
it you can put
one cheese or like whatever and it is
it's amazing i mean you compare it with
anything
so yeah uh my wife macaroni and cheese
my mom's
like either one i guess it's off the
chain
all right spice look for that dm
saturday night from me um that's the way
i'll reach out to you
um and um it's coming
oh yeah i'm i i'm it's so rare for me to
be so
confident but you know i think we got
the right quarterback now
and everything's looking good and i
don't know
you know i don't know if you know this
game could go either way
don't don't the heck don't try to act
like y'all got the
upper edge because you don't i don't
know i mean
can chris can you look this up no i'm
i'm asking my guy here chris brock what
do you want you just look it up on the
internet can
somebody who's owen 5 talk back
is that allowed
i don't believe is that allowed can you
look i don't know you look it up i don't
know where that is on the internet to
look that up but
can somebody whose team is o and five
for the first time in their lush history
talk back hey rick yes sir rich you know
what
oh you're still there i was on the team
i was i was on a team
with uh the san francisco 49ers and it
was a year we went 2 and 14.
but guess what yes all those 16 games
guess who won
me i won my team lost
but i won
michigan's a two-point favorite oh who
knew i didn't think that
those words would come out of your mouth
for the rest of this year two-point
favorite
all right spice thanks for the call man
have a great thanksgiving always great
catching up with you hey man you
man king's propellers very best in the
world you got it that's uh check it out
on uh
spice spice adams on his twitter and
instagram feed talking about kingsford
pellets